The feds were interested in
taking down the whole mafia.
I'm just one more guy
putting a piece of the puzzle
together for them.
This special agent was
gonna be my handler.
He gave me this small recorder,
and it went into a jockstrap.
And he's like, yeah, just put
it on over your underwear.
You have to record everybody.
There's no exceptions.
I mean, he started
going over rules.
Can't leave the wire.
No violent, none at all.
Otherwise, the deal's off.
He gave me my code
name, Break Shot.
Break Shot is the first
shot in a pool game
when they spread
out all the balls,
and that's basically what
they wanted me to do--
help smash the mob into pieces.
The deal was six
months to a year,
but I knew my life was
about to change forever.
The first time I
was wearing a wire,
I was going to meet a capo named
Jimmy Katchi, a very powerful
captain in the Colombo Family.
Contrary to popular belief,
there is no agents waiting
in a van around the corner.
When they pressed the
button, I realized
that I was about
to go out, and I'm
gonna record one of the most
dangerous men in the world.
I thought in my
head, this is it.
This is for real.
[music playing]
Wearing a wire, you
think that everyone can
see that thing in your pocket.
[music continues]
Hey, Kenji, how you doing?
Sit down, sit down.
KENJI (VOICEOVER): I
sit down at the table.
And in walks this big, Italian
guy who I've never seen before.
He identified on tape.
He said, I'm a wise
guy just like Jimmy.
He starts talking about the
inner workings of the mafia.
He wants to propose a guy into
the organization from Vegas.
And I'm just
sitting there still,
hoping that the recorder
is picking up every word
because I know it's good.
He talked about the
organization structure,
and this is what
the FBI is after.
This is the kind of
evidence that they want.
And then, I start to feel
this warm sensation coming
from the recorder,
but I just kinda
blow it off because the
guy is talking a lot.
I want to let things unfold.
And I'm looking at him,
and it's starting to get
hotter and hotter and hotter.
I'm realizing that this thing is
starting to burn in my crotch.
You OK?
All of a sudden, it
just gets unbearable.
Finally, I just
told him I gotta go.
[music playing]
I met up with my handler.
He asked me, so what happened?
And I told him it
was burning so hot,
I thought my nuts were on fire.
He just started laughing.
He's like oh, I
heard that sometimes
they malfunction like that.
But I was relieved because he
told me that the tape was good.
It was valuable because it would
help them find the structure
and figure out who's doing what.
As time went on, I
started to get it down.
[indistinct chattering]
I learned how to elicit
what I wanted out of people.
Your business-- you bring
it to me, I get it done.
Hey, bartender,
another drink over here.
But the fear never goes.
You always have to worry
about being found out.
Almost every single
person I knew
had been involved in a murder
at one point or another,
and I was gathering intel
on them for the FBI.
I started seeing that I could
actually make a difference.
That encouraged me to
do more because I felt
like I accomplished something.
Raise it to five.
At this point, I'd been
undercover for six months.
I was supposed to
be wearing a wire,
but I decided to continue on
because I began to feel a lot
of pride in what I was doing.
[music playing]
The FBI wanted me to
aim higher, go bigger.
And I knew that meant
the New York families.
It's the epicenter of the mafia.
It's where the power is.
So I made a trip to New York.
That's when I met
Eddie Garafolo.
My guy, Kenji.
Good to meet you.
Eddie Garafolo was a Columbo
associate from New York,
and he was very well connected.
And he wanted me to move to
Brooklyn and be in his crew.
And being invited there
was a huge step up.
This was my chance to get
intel on the real big fish
in the mafia.
But I had no idea what I
was getting myself into.
[music playing]